[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tom pelicero joining us on loan from the
nfl network explain the nfl memo
that came out yesterday tom well dan the
headline item
is of course that the nfl is now telling
clubs
in no uncertain terms that if any game
is canceled and cannot be made up
uh within the regularly scheduled 18
game season
and it involves a outbreak among
unvaccinated
players then the team that is the has
the outbreak
is going to forfeit they are going to
take a loss
in terms of playoff seating they're also
going to be responsible for reimbursing
costs to the other team paying their
visiting a
team share pool and potentially
depending if protocols are violated
subject to
additional discipline you know last year
of course there were
a couple of significant outbreaks one in
tennessee one in baltimore the league
grand probes on those but
at no point was a forfeit ever
considered um you had some of the same
ramifications the players on neither
team
would get paid if a game were canceled
the nfl made a bunch of adjustments
moved some things around
they were able to play uh all 256 games
in the 17 week season but they also
always held out
the possibility they could use and add a
week 18
to make up any games the in this memo it
makes very clear in
bold face type we do not anticipate
adding a 19th week to the season and
even goes so far as to say
that if the team is not ready to play
when they are scheduled to play under
the constitution and bylaws
that is conduct detrimental and the
commissioner could take
action against a club if they
are not able to play a game and
specifically if
it is because they had unvaccinated
individuals who tested positive and
caused an outbreak
what role has the nfl players
association played
the nfl and the nfl pa have negotiated
all the protocols to this point
including
uh the fact that players on neither team
would get paid
in terms of team discipline in terms of
the forfeit and the loss
those are league decisions that they
make
unilaterally because that would not
involve the players so the players
compensation does not change but in
terms of
all the protocols the differences
between vaccinated and under
unvaccinated individuals mask wearing
the daily testing versus testing every
two weeks
the significant travel restrictions the
nflpa
has uh jointly negotiating all of those
and in fact the union sent a memo
to all players yesterday that once again
reiterated what is really the top line
item in all this that
uh the unions medical experts say that
you have tested vaccines that are
effective even though they have
maintained that it's every player's
individual choice the league is not
mandating it
it's a very uh strong message from the
union and the league there are upwards
of 78 percent of players within the
league that have at least one vaccine
shot
and they are aiming to get as many
people vaccinated as possible before we
get to september
yeah i wonder about you know you talk
about individual rights and some of
these players have brought this up
so what does a team do to accommodate
for the lack of a better word
somebody like deandre hopkins or cole
beasley who says i don't want to get
vaccinated but
i still want to play well they're
allowed to do that because the
vaccine is not mandated for the players
but every team is going to be
individually having to
sort out how they're arranging their
locker room you know we've seen in other
sports
whether it's the yankees outbreak among
vaccinated individuals whether it's
olympic athletes
you've got vaccinated people who are
testing positive and they're being
pulled out of competition now the nfl
memo also yesterday
uh made reference to the fact that
vaccinated individuals potentially can
return to play sooner they only need to
have two
if they're asymptomatic they would need
to have two negative tests 24 hours
apart
and then they can return there's no
mandatory 10-day waiting period but of
course
if you test positive and it's a real
positive you're probably going to test
positive for a while but still i've
talked to medical officials with teams
who have
i wouldn't call them concerns but
certainly questions about as you see the
delta variant as you see other variants
of this virus
as you see case numbers uh double around
the country every couple of weeks right
now
you know the place we're in in late july
is that going to be
uh significantly better than where we
might be in september if the case
numbers continue to rise and if so
do you roll back those restrictions
because i can tell you this dan
when you talk about i've talked to many
whether it's players
coaches agents for players front office
people there's a lot of people who had
some level of hesitancy
and did not want to take the vaccine and
in a lot of cases
people ended up getting it because they
don't want their lives to be like last
year they want to be able to get back to
living like normal in the cases of
coaches
and front office people they can't even
be around the team really there's
major restrictions unless you get an
exemption if you do not get vaccinated
so now all of a sudden if the league
comes back and says
actually you are going to have mass
actually we are still going to have
separated travel
actually the sun is going to close again
that would be
a really hard sell and so the nfl for
the moment is just continuing to
emphasize what they did yesterday which
is just
here's all the reasons again that it is
going to be in the best interest of you
your team and the league if you get
vaccinated i'm federally mandated to ask
you about aaron rodgers
if you think he'll show up what's the
end game here
the one thing that i've heard
consistently dan from people who know
aaron rodgers is everyone believes
that he has and has had a plan
and that he has not communicated that
plan
to the powers-to-be the packers have not
been
told anything about whether or not uh he
is going to show up
there are certain levers that he
potentially could pull between he could
show up on time
he could decide to hold out five days
into camp eat 250
000 in fines and then show up day six
before they can go after his bonus money
he could choose to temporarily retire he
could
choose to pull what uh sometimes called
a hold in where you show up but
basically
don't practice but this collective
bargaining agreement looks upon that a
little bit more harshly in terms of
there's a material failure to uh perform
your duties then
uh you know there's additional
discipline that can come into play so
you know you still have a lot of moving
parts the packers have made
clear publicly and privately for months
that they are not trading aaron rodgers
uh i am not
under the impression based upon what i
know that that has changed
at all now is there any chance that it
would change if you got into
mid-august or september or october or
toward the trade deadline
and aaron rodgers is still not there
that's hypothetical
as of now but the packers absolutely
want aaron rodgers back
they've stood at the ready whether it's
the contract that we reported back in
march and april that they had tried to
negotiate and that they had not been
able to strike a deal
whether it's other potential changes in
the organization they're basically
saying
tell us what you need to make this work
and to this point
aaron rodgers hasn't really done that i
know you had a busy morning
thank you for uh making some time for us
tom thank you and uh have a great
weekend
anytime dan you too that's tom pelicero
nfl network reporter